tout un après midi avec le clan fayda on
va pas s'ennuyer tous les styles oui
[Rires]
et on va vivre une fête typiquement
traditionnel de balle c'est la veille
des parties puis la fête la saint joseph
évidemment on va manger
[Musique]
c'est bon non ça devrait être assez
joseph et déjà
il ya quelqu'un qui s'est assis puis à
manger s'habiller diot saint joseph
cette petite pâtisserie italienne les
épauler et cuisine est
traditionnellement le 19 mars chaque
année pour souligner la fête de san jose
paix et la fête des pères célébrée à
cette date en italie une tradition
reprises ici par ces restaurateurs
n'osent pas c'est la faute des parents
vis quelque chose qui est inventé au sud
de l'italie pourquoi c'est du vent au
nord de l'italie ils connaissent pas les
épaules et on en fait mille d'habitude
chez germain puis on ouvre les portes à
10 heures puis à une affaire à 14 heures
ces sondages il se voudrait cette
traditionnelle qui pourraient cuit au
four ou qu'on peut faire frire mais
mieux free bah oui que cuit au faux mais
c'est comme un bail et xen dame italien
c'est ça faisait quand et trois chefs en
cuisine qui dessinent
elena
se complémentent finalement oui parce
que tu es moi j'ai mes forces stéphanois
ces folles les allaite toutes les portes
la santé
la pâte se fait dans une casserole comme
une pâte à choux j'ai mis le lait le
sucre le sel et le var une fois que le
mélange les convulsions on va rajouter
la farine d'un trait d'un très résilient
force et quand on va voir un mélange qui
aussi être légèrement humide donc faut
quand même le laisser cuire pour qu'il
devient un peu plus sec pourquoi vous le
souhaitez comme ça donc on va introduire
dollars qui savoir refroidir la partie
un jaune comme ça la voir et quand on
ajoute les oeufs savons pas quoi d'une
église a erré la place de jaune d'oeuf
ya plein de l'iss est il donc ça va
faire une émission parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de lait de beaucoup de grands
c'est comme faire un maillot puis le
placer la structure c'est ça qui fait
monter ses grands amis combien ces six
mais qui a quand même un test avec les
doigts pour savoir si la bad eh bien
c'est parfait les alvéoles c'est la
structure qu'on va retrouver ici ça va
se retrouver ici
dans un sac à paris
il faut offrir à 350 la bonne
température
oui il faut pas que ça soit trop chaud
parce que sinon ça va plus vite ça vaut
créé à l'extérieur mais sa popularité
et s'il lui n'est pas assez chaud là par
vale absorbé trop d'huile avec ça va
être plus gréer solution de sa
pile on les laisse cuire à peu près 1 6
me 9
c'est vrai quand ça prend cette belle
couleur dorée et que cette triple de
volume ice aux symboles emma est encore
chaud mais les jeunes et j'ai léger
léger ajoutant rubrique à tort il
les cdg
on mélangera pas de la crème fouettée
avec la ricotta une zone c ca % rico
avec le tmx est on va lisser la docteure
puis après on ajoute ceux d'annie les
astuces pont puis à la fin d'un
feuilleton mais le championnat semble
brisée
pis si c'est ça qu'on veut voir ou cissé
je suis à main exactement si le secret
c'est de l'est parce que le lactose
c'est plus cycle et donc ça va donner un
petit peu plus de couleurs du plus de
goût on peut utiliser de l'eau mais si
tu utilises de l'eau souvent que la
croûte est plus ferme ils se les amis
l'accès sévèrement les secrets parce que
mike d'habitude si donne la recette il
didelot tout le temps
qui faisait beau ces manifs et qui so
c'est le job pour les aides pour
l'instant 12 mp on tire on peut à la
rigueur a ajouté j'ai pas moins de pâte
de pistache ont peu de témoins
tartinades chocolat noisette qu'on
connaît bien et on est la das a fait un
autre saveur de bronze c'est quand même
ce puits on peut rajouter des saveurs si
on veut se mêler si on va se promener
dans la rue avec ça les gens vont sauter
là dessus sur le oui
l'a fait chez les fighters si beaucoup
le partage et les neuf s'est fait
plaisir comment tu le prononce je ne
fais pas comme une forme d'epo l'on vous
savez que ce que c'est
les dépôts l'est aujourd'hui saint
joseph
la
[Musique]
fsb
m